so as many of you know we have a
shortage of what is called PPE right now
personal protective equipment this
includes things like masks and gloves
face shields goggles other equipment
that healthcare professionals need to
safely treat people with coronavirus
without themselves being at risk of the
disease and to try to minimize the
possibility of spreading it to other
people for weeks now Donald Trump has
been very transparently blaming the
previous administration that's code for
Barack Obama for the shortage it's been
panic at the state level for hospitals
trying to get more PPE right now even
most of the coronavirus tests require
the administrator to wear PPE hopefully
that will change soon we're seeing some
new rapid self swab tests come to market
as Trump says including one from Abbott
which will start to be available maybe
as early as this week if they're telling
the truth but we're really short on PPE
because it's required for tests and for
many other reasons friends of mine who
are I have two friends who are yo ER
doctors here in Boston work for
different hospital administrators and
both were told they will have one mask
to use all day normally you would change
normally you'd have a face shield and
you change the mask between patients and
put the face shield over it they will
have one mask for the entire day well it
has now been revealed that Donald Trump
sent a ton of PPE to China nearly 18
tons of supplies in February but is now
blaming the previous administration for
the shortage check it out here's Trump
talking about the old system inherited
from Barack Obama I this administration
inherited an obsolete broken old system
that wasn't meant for this we discarded
that system and we now have a new system
that can do millions of people as you
need them but we had to get rid of a
broken old system that didn't work it
worked only in a very limited basis and
we're very proud of what we
done it's incredible what we've done and
this system will now serve for the
future for future problems hopefully you
don't have a problem like this but
something will come up we have now a
great system and it's almost fully in
gear but it's able to test millions of
people but we inherited a broken old
frankly a terrible system we fixed it
and we've done a great job and we
haven't been given the credit that we
deserve that I can tell you well it
turns out that a lot of what we are now
experiencing is Trump's own doing so
aside from you know we're in year four
of Trump's presidency Obama gave Trump
the pandemic response playbook the State
Department admitted back on February 7th
that they facilitated the transportation
of 18 tons of medical supplies to
Chinese people including masks gowns
gauze respirators and other vital
materials Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
tweeted a video of a plane being
unloaded that was filled with our stuff
back on February 7th we gave them the
stuff we sent them the masks gowns and
all of the stuff we are now short on
which Trump is making States compete
over so it's actually an even more
deranged situation than we believed
which was already by the way very very
deranged Trump didn't take the threat
seriously here called it the Chinese
virus blames China now we have no masks
we're short on all of the stuff that
Trump is failing to secure for our state
governors and now we find out he sent a
whole bunch of it to China these last
six are now closer to eight weeks have
been the biggest failure of the trump
presidency and we may end up I hope not
we may end up with a death toll that is
not just 10 times higher but may be 50
times higher then it needed to be
because of failure after embarrassing
failure by Donald Trump now let me say
something else because I know we're
gonna have a bunch of people jump in and
attack me over this I want to be really
clear this
not me doing some hyper nationalist
argument about Trump's should only worry
about Americans and not Chinese people
that's not the issue here the issues
here are multiple first the fact that
Trump has and continues to blame the
previous administration for things that
were his own decisions
that caused the problems that's tragic
it's disgusting and it I fear that it is
working actually with a lot of his
followers saying this was actually
Obama's fault number two the fact that
Trump was sending this stuff to China on
February 7th but only in early March did
he start taking seriously the procuring
of masks and PPE for our hospitals tells
us that for a full month from early
February to early March
Trump knew we were low in the stockpile
because he sent a bunch of the stockpile
to China but he didn't do a damn thing
about starting to replace it for our
hospitals until March so again the
criticism is not how dare we help China
that's not the critique the critique is
clearly this is not Obama's fault
but more importantly Trump had a signal
on February 7th or earlier at minimum
that we need to replenish our own supply
of masks and other PPE and he didn't do
it and now it's become a scramble that
continues to be a scramble as we are now
days from entering April it's
incompetence at every turn it's not
about we should never help China it's
about don't blame Obama for your mistake
and also don't act like nobody could
have foreseen this when you knew you
depleted your own stockpile on February
7th and then we've got press conference
is still happening on like March 25th
where he's saying we're trying to get
masks we're trying to get this stuff
disgusting don't fall for it